let's talk about neural link for a
second
so what's the concept in general the
concept of neural link is that i'm going
to take
whatever knowledge is encoded in my
brain directly transfer it into your
brain
so this is a beautiful fascinating and
extremely
sort of you know appealing concept but i
see a lot of challenges
surrounding that the first one is we
have no
idea how to even begin to understand how
knowledge is encoded
in a person's brain i mean i told you
about this paper that we had recently
with leeway tai
and asaf marco that basically was
looking at these
engrams that are formed with
combinations of neurons that co-fire
when a stimulus happens
where we can go into a mouse and select
those neurons that fire by marking them
and then see what happens when they
first fire and then select the neurons
that fire again when the experience is
repeated
these are the recall neurons and then
there's the
the memory consolidation neurons so
we're starting to understand a little
bit of sort of the distributed
nature of knowledge and coding and
experience in coding
in the human brain and in the mouse
brain and
the concept that will understand that
sufficiently one day
to be able to take a snapshot of
what does that scene from dave losing
his mind of
how losing his mind and talking to dave
how is that seen encoded in your mind
imagine the complexity of that
but now imagine suppose that we solve
this problem
and the next enormous challenge is how
do i go and modify
the next person's brain to now create
the same exact neural connections
so that's an enormous challenge right
there so basically it's not just reading
it's not writing and again
what if something goes wrong i don't
want to even think about that
that's number two and number three who
says
that the way that you encode dave i'm
losing my mind
and i encode dave i'm losing my mind
is anywhere near each other basically
maybe the way that i'm encoding it
is twisted with my childhood memories of
running through
you know the pebbles in greece and yours
is twisted with your childhood memories
growing up in russia and there's no way
that i can take my encoding and put it
into your brain because it'll
a mess things up and b be incompatible
with your own unique experiences so
that's telepathic communication from
human to humans fascinating
you